[Music]
starting with a game that Pete and Rob
you just played today for the first time
Kellie if you played dead cells yet I
love this game yeah fun I mean I wish I
started playing it sooner one of those
scenarios where everyone's talking about
it I'm like okay sounds good I'll file
it away I'll get back to it early access
still yeah but it doesn't feel like it
feels really full it feels really good
for those who don't know it's it's a
side-scrolling 2d people calling it
there are some light Metroidvania item
gating elements but it's more of a rogue
legacy if you played that on it is a
roguelike game so it's procedurally
generated levels but you see the
character just picked up a cell there
you can kind of see the bottom left of
the screen the blue orbs those are kind
of souls from Dark Souls I guess if you
want to compare it to that because there
are some you know you lose those and
then but it is very much rogue legacy is
one of my favorite games and this is
more like that - the mutations of your
ancestors but you get to start you get
past like this first area you get to the
sewers or the promenade and then you get
to you know you can pick up actual
permanent upgrades which abilities you
can kind of grow these vines out of
these small little clumps or like I said
those are the Metroid actually
Metroidvania item getting ailments but
you'll also pick up like here you'll get
a magic increase for your abilities if
I'm blueprints for their items yeah you
find blueprints and then you you invest
those cells into different upgrades and
then once you invest those cells that's
permanent those cells those cell
upgrades are pretty extensive like as
far as the pages yeah there's a lot um
I got I think my peen I was talking
about thing my favorite weapon so far is
the dual wielding knives cuz I'm not
just that the third is always like a
critical and it's kind of just combo you
can do and I've been so you see on map
TLB down there you can see like help
files you can upgrade it so you can have
more than one each life and then when
you get to the checkpoints
you can refill those it's very much like
Estus flasks from Dark Souls or blood
vials from blood-borne which you can't
really tell just by watching this is how
tight yeah the controls are very
responsive and it like it doesn't feel
like there's any sort of like weird
weightiness or floatiness that you have
to get used to so that immediately made
me like hooked but then it's just like
the presentation
and the sort of like the quick little
combat you know scenarios introduces
very quickly teaches you that there are
a lot of enemies you have to deal with
in very different ways yeah not to
mention as you can see now the game's
gorgeous it's it's good for the
animations are so impressive just like
that just getting the daggers like your
your pose when you're holding them and
running and then just like I don't know
finishing a kill is just super rewarding
with those things yeah looking at all
the work that's already gone into this
it makes me wonder about the team that's
created it because there there is a lot
of effort clearly that's been put into
this game motion twin right the
developer but like I don't know yeah
background but I'm super curious now
after seeing this I'm like look into it
you mean yeah yeah it's uh it's
fantastic I don't know what they'll keep
adding with early access maybe they'll
flesh out there's not much of a story at
all there's a guy at the beginning that
tells you like uh you seems you've lost
your head there's anyway that's right
and then he goes because that explains
why you can't talk to me yeah like it's
like the the writing is really endearing
like I've been really enjoying it like
people are pretty mean right you come to
a merging he's like now get the hell out
of here yeah he's kind of yeah the
merchants right yeah he cannot that's
what the guy you invest your cells with
and then you die you lose all those
cells you like rogue legacy you can get
this upgrade where you keep us
percentage your gold when you respawn
though there's a carrot right there
that's like a one-time health upgrade
but you see these numbers above the
weapons and the the trigger the magic
abilities and your health those you
actually have to start over an upgrade
later on but yeah the farthest I found
the game they've kind of hinted at that
I'm halfway through and again I've
played probably six hours at this point
and I have upgraded my twin blades to
about they're doing like plus 20% damage
so they're awesome but the thing is you
like I said it's procedurally generated
so I might not even find those so it's
kind of a risk to what you're investing
in but that's half the fun the enemy
variety the farther you get in is really
good those red ones are the range kind
of zombies that you see in this area but
then you start getting into a lot of
enemies that can shoot through walls
which makes it a little tougher and here
you see oh here's that one guy did you
get that ice blast there the one the
first item there and then I tried using
it but the lovable time it takes to use
long
yeah I mean I prefer to just oh and then
and then there's there's these little
touches that you kind of these emergent
things you don't realize on if you do a
ground slam you stun people anytime
you're dropping just hold down and press
it down an a I guess a small tip and
then doors don't open them just hit them
because they'll stun it almost
flashbangs the enemies behind it and I
get like a small amount of something and
resource from dodging is huge I never
use shield if I can help it but dodging
you go through anybody especially when
you start finding the shield guys I I
didn't know you were I mean I obviously
there was going to be controller support
I didn't figured to plug that up at I
imagine that would be a lot better oh
yeah controller playing the ps4
controller just felt immediately good
and it was worked but like no problems
yeah I've been using xbox one it feels
great as well then this guy you need
spend your cells here here you go so you
can see so the health file up top left -
right there with the 52 you need 52
cells to be able to carry - I actually
got that so every between these
checkpoints right after this merchant
you'll see that there's this giant flask
of health potion that you refill at this
game is fantastic as someone who really
likes Metroidvania switch that's less of
the comparison I would make them - rogue
legacy or something there are like I
said a Callie you just saw those clumps
it said tickle that's you grow vines on
them later those are the permanent
ability to keep and that's where the
item gating comes in like a like a
Metroid game yeah yeah but it is more if
you liked rogue legacy which if you
haven't played that you should it's on
Xbox one and ps4 now as of last year two
years ago it's on Vita 2 and Vita yeah
you should play that game rogue legacy
would be fantastic on switch now that I
think about it it's pretty good on Vita
Mike yeah I don't have a be done you
know this no I love my V I've been
considering buying a Vita recently um
for cuz I after professional add own
persona 4 I want to play spelunky
danganronpa final fancies attack - dinks
yes God love God I think I asked Pete
maybe weekly what the best platform to
play tactics on is and what's the answer
you always give me play the PlayStation
classics version on Vita
yeah or on your ps3 that you still have
hooked up because you're cool like me oh
cool I do have my hope that well it's
not hooked up but it's stacked on my
like entertainment center I just a plug
it in there you go um yeah play dead
cells this games awesome like I said
it's in early access but if I didn't say
that and they didn't have a notify at
the beginning you might
even know it doesn't feel like there's
much missing um I don't I haven't found
anything I dislike about it the only
thing I dislike is kind of inherent to
like a roguelike is sometimes you won't
come across items that you like and
you'll almost feel like you're not
having the full experience in this
playthrough but again that's the game's
design I guess the blood sword this
thing it that whoever I don't know whose
footage this is whoever's I think this
is Jake maybe whoever is playing right
here the blood swords good just causes
bleeding damage it's mine I know for a
fact this is not you I watched you play
earlier yeah you're only like 20 minutes
in though right Shh
20 minutes too far what you like do you
like this from a play no I really do
like it
oh the controller yeah I know I am doing
it I want to play more of this for sure
it's tough but it feels so good that you
don't mind dying and starting oh yeah
it's like you can see here it's getting
this is not even a crazy sick it's oh
here use weird scarecrow things that
shield enemies so right there you can't
hurt them until you kill it up top it's
like a practice dummy that like a knight
might use or something it's which is
great it's before sorry I don't want me
to keep cutting you off okay but it's
really the enemy variety later on gets
really great
um the my point kind of past but just
talking about like you don't mind dying
because it feels so good it's like
something that's really inherently
important to this kind of game yeah that
that intrigue like obviously I'm pulled
in by the the art style and it's
gorgeous and it looks great but that I
think is the thing that's going to keep
me playing did you get the chance to
play rogue legacy ever mm-hmm you should
try that and this um I like I said rogue
legacy cellar-door games I believe two
people made it I think and it came out
2013 which is a year were a few of those
kind of games come out rogue legacy and
risk of rain which has a sequel they
announced but risk of rain itself is
made by two people as well when they
were at Washington University I think I
was two college students they made it
and it was kind of a sleeper roguelike
hit back at the kind of the peak of the
roguelike craze this game honestly
design wise and like I said robe like
kind of 2d side-scrolling feels like it
might have come out a few years ago not
to say anything about its quality at all
it just feels like a few years ago this
kind of game was like everybody was
wanting yeah
it might be fair to say that you know
all that energy and interest back then
inspired the creation of this maybe
mm-hmm yeah what is like five years ago
at this point now some of those games
yeah it's getting there yeah it's
getting there but definitely you know
like you know talking about these things
feeling fun to go back to that point
super important because like rogue
legacy I respected the hell out of that
game but I hated getting like bad
genetics yeah like different characters
and I would stop playing at three points
and that's kind of the cipa thing here
you might run into playthroughs where I
say play through but it could be like
five minutes it could be three hours but
you run into parts where you might not
find the blood sword or the dual daggers
or the ice blast or the bear trap you
see down here this I'm gonna keep
playing this this is kind of what I'm
playing right now and I really like it
it is on Steam early access I believe
it's $20 I'm not mistaken yeah if you
want to go check it out I highly
encourage people to even if that's not
your type of game it's worth checking
out
and you can go play that as it now I
think was 16 dollars 16 will sail hmm I
don't like there's a full release date
but again you might not even know it's
early access if you if you just want to
get in play now
[Music]